wow what a what a dramatic intro the uh
the TV man just had now did you see him
do that well did
you watching again what he had his fade
in what
oh okay I missed that one uh well uh
there's a lot of important announcements
to to make at first and so I should uh
so everybody please pay careful
attention
uh first important announcement is that
the textbooks have arrived at the
bookstore
the uh this writing mathematics well is
there and uh uh and the second important
announcement is that since you now have
a textbook I have now given you a
homework assignment and the homework
assignment is based in part on the
textbook
um so the homework is going to be due
two weeks from today but I recommend
that you begin work on it now uh just so
that uh uh you can come and talk to the
Tas when they have office hours next
week and the week after that for any
problems you have understanding it so
there's a do you have a copy of this
handout that gives the that gives the
homework assignment
please raise your hand if you do not
have the if you do not have the handout
please raise your hand if you do have
the handout
ah good response great okay so now that
the uh uh
let me explain the the uh uh
the the idea of this homework problem
uh it in in this book
um which you'll uh you go find is not
difficult to read it uh in a short time
there's an appendix at the end and he
talks about uh the use of symbols and
this is a uh this is an important lesson
to learn when you're when you're
presenting any mathematical argument and
uh so he goes through a case study and
the point of his case study was to take
an art an article that had particularly
uh uh poor use of symbols and uh
replaces it by Improvement and in this
he has for example before and after it
before is in this kind of brick brackets
and after is this so he for example he
replaces this symbol by this one thereby
eliminating uh the letter c that you
didn't need and I and having and having
another notation that's equally good
then sometimes he can replace this
symbol by this symbol which in other
words he he doesn't need it at all and
he can so so he took he took the article
and simplified it down down and he come
he came out with an article which he
sort of only hints at but uh but but it
is left with a simplified version now I
read this appendix and I and uh and I
thought well I can't just give you this
uh I can't just say uh now take his
simplified version and simplify it once
more use the same ideas again on his
version and and come up with a with a
better one uh but that's that's your
assignment but what I did was I decided
to give you
um
a a simplified version in other words
this is what I'm going to presenting
here is is what I think uh Gilman is
saying is the simplified version of of
the original proof and now what you're
supposed to do is start with this and
then rewrite it uh it goes on up to here
and re rewrite it in a way that that you
know makes the notation yet better uh
you see that the notation still has
cases where T sub n super a sub K which
is uh which is not would be nice if we
could we could do without it
and various subscripted subscripts and
so on now that now he was reacting to
the original article which has which had
in it uh
uh which he thinks is the is the
all-time Champion for the for the most
complicated symbol that ever appeared in
a paper and he said uh actually it was
printed correctly
um sir Pinsky must have climbed into the
printing press for a last minute check
now this message now sir pinski was uh
is a uh it was a was a great uh
mathematician of his Century in this
book concrete math I'm writing I've got
one reference to a paper he wrote in
1909 and another reference to a paper he
wrote in 1959 so so he was a prolific
mathematician for a long for the time
actually his name is uh it has a has a
accent over the N if you spell it
properly and this was the um this was
the original paper that uh that Gilman
used in his in his article in in his uh
to base his appendix and the uh and the
monster symbol appears right there and
and uh Penske being polish in there so
he instead of a pixius quality he used
another one down here yeah okay so
so now uh the thing was ifinski being
being a great mathematician still his
notation was so it barely confused him
and he said there's a bug in his proof
and so another so so a few years later
there had to be a correction to the note
of sabinski uh by a Japanese
mathematician uh this is came out to
what 36 or 37 or something like this and
so now he he revises the uh the paper
and uh we still have the same the same
formula but he at least uh gets occur
gets a A corrected uh version of it and
he goes through and makes all kinds of
other things which turn out to be
unnecessary
uh so so so Gilman took this paper
rewrote it and and uh the rewrite is
what what I give you here is the uh is
the beginning of your homework problem
your job will be to to rewrite it again
now I'll give you a couple of things
first of all the subject of the the
mathematics is not trivial I mean sir
Pinsky wouldn't publish something that
was that any any uh uh freshman could do
um but um uh still it doesn't involve
any anything other than functions and
sets uh it doesn't use calculus it
doesn't use complicated complicated
ideas of logic or any particular
everything is sort of uh self-contained
in this proof If you know what a set is
and of course it needs to be a countable
set and a one-to-one correspondence in a
function these are things about sets
that that they taught in the new math
and so maybe you got it somewhere along
the line in your education if not the
Tas are here to help you out and explain
explain it's like a function is a is a
procedure and uh you know
um now uh the other thing is uh uh what
why did supinski work on this at all and
that's because the one of the big
unsolved problems with mathematics uh at
the time in the 30s was the so-called
Continuum hypothesis This was
um uh is there is there an Infinity
between
um between the Continuum and accountable
set is there is there so accountable set
means that it's in one-to-one
correspondence with the integers a
Continuum means it's in one-to-one
correspondence with the real numbers uh
the question is is there any is there
anything Infinity in in between there is
there something that had more elements
that couldn't be put into one-to-one
correspondence with a with a countable
set but still could not all be put into
one one corresponds with the real
numbers but was a subset of the real
numbers and uh this was a non-solved
problem well sipinski is is showing that
that if if you could do he's trying to
he's trying to prove this uh he's trying
to to to make a step towards proving it
by saying if you could construct
something then you could prove the
Continuum hypothesis so so the theorem
says uh it has a hypothesis in here and
and don't worry if the hypothesis seems
hard to satisfy it it might be
impossible to satisfy I think we now
know that it is uh impossible because
the conclusion is that then the
Continuum hypothesis is true because he
says anyone accountable subset of the
real numbers
will will make will be mapped into the
real numbers by by all by all but
finally many functions and that means
then that any uncountable subset would
have to be have as many elements as the
real numbers and this would prove to
continue my project so anyway this is
the background but you don't have to
understand the theorem in order to do
this homework exercise you just have to
have to uh have to reproduce the the
mathematical argument and even after
after you've done so you might not have
any idea why sirpinski thought of this
argument or anything like that you might
be able to do it but it's it's mostly uh
an exercise in writing where you're
trying to uh uh uh you know the
some of these things are are in logic
can't always be psyched out in the same
way as as things uh in physics where
where you can sort of push think push
something a little way and it's still
and it's still approximately right in
logic if if one little if one little uh
it's like a computer program if you if
if you if you lose the if if there's one
weak link the whole argument breaks down
um but but um this sometimes makes
logical things too uh hard to uh higher
continuity to use in intuition
um anyway the the main idea here would
be to try to find a way to recast this
so that the idea of the proof Remains
the Same but the notation is much better
and and the proof actually will then get
shorter and it'll be clearish what
what's interest what's your Pinsky did
uh
uh when you when you solve this problem
so come back with if you don't
understand the assignment ask me next
week but don't ask me Thursday night the
night before it's due uh this is a three
minute course after all
and so uh
um and I gave you this first homework
but this assignment will be graded so do
do your best on it and try to what we'd
like to do is actually have the best
possible
for the first time in the work in the
history of the world the best possible
proof of sirpinsky's theorem and this is
something also that you find when you're
doing any other mathematical right
certainly if you're ever writing a
textbook you have you're going to have
somebody else's uh uh work that you're
trying to find an exposition of and you
want to present it in a in a way often
better than they did because they were
so close to it they couldn't see
um the the same way as as somebody like
you who's being able to look at it and
be able to make a simplified
presentation of the of the basic ideas
so so you so you look at the essence
everything of this proof and find out
what is really what what is really
necessary what is what really is the
structure of the argument and then once
you find that you could choose a
notation for that structure Yeah you
sort of it's sort of like late binding
in computer science where you don't
declare something until you know until
you know what it has to be what it has
to be don't don't introduce a subscript
unless unless you uh or superscript
unless you unless you're sure that it's
necessary
sort of a clue as to as to this homework
homework assignment okay
so any other questions on that ask me
next week
um
uh another thing I brought with me today
is the resources the resource books that
I uh that I work with all the time as
I'm writing I wanted to show you some of
these things that are available
depending on how much uh uh
um how much writing you're going to do
you should you should consider
purchasing some of these oh for sure and
I and uh and and many of many of you
will know these things but um let me
start with the biggest one first this uh
do people know what the OED means OED
Oxford English Dictionary now this is a
dictionary that started out in uh
about a hundred years ago
and uh and is supposed to really be the
definitive source of information about
the English language and a wonderful uh
project is going on now in in Canada to
to put it all on computers and I and
they say that maybe next year will be
the year and so on and and they have a
lot of good computer scientists working
on this and the people in England uh
been been very active uh Gathering
continually Gathering uh Source sources
now the uh now you can if you if if you
don't need it very much then you can
always go to the library to use it when
you need to but otherwise if you there's
a lot of book clubs that you can join
which give you this for a free uh
subscription to their book club or
something like this and it's a compact
Edition it's also known as the squint
print edition it comes with a it comes
with a magnifying glass and I always I I
don't know if uh um if how much you can
zoom on this can I bet you can't I bet
you can't get it because it really does
give you a headache if you look at it
with oh you can almost read that WoW
instead of the said of the agent I can
see ah my goodness I can see that on TV
I can't read it I can't read it in front
of him here in the real thing but anyway
uh this is uh
16 Vines condensing the two or something
like this and and uh
um and it gives you uh uh the citations
of how the word was used back in history
as far as they know and and so that you
can see seek see all kinds of different
things now if you if you have to find a
for example if you have to find a weird
quotation about any subject to impress
your friends or something like this so I
when I did the trivia hunt last year I I
needed uh an old use of the word bite
and so I looked up bite in here and uh
here it was in Chaucer uh and uh so uh
you know for historical references also
just you know it's very interesting that
they they chose the quotations well uh
for the for the different words then
there's this supplement which has come
out in four volumes and they cost I
don't know I think more than 100 a piece
so you don't want you so so you don't
necessarily have to buy them but I I
really uh love this um uh and so this
tells you uh this is for example
published last year and brought the and
brought the whole the whole dictionary
uh pretty much up to date let's see
let's look up
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious yeah
this is when I had to look up to find
out how it was hyphenated
uh because I was using it as an example
in a textbook
in fact I needed it before the book came
out so I wrote to them and they sent me
they they said they gave me a a chance
to look at it yeah here we go so here's
the
here's the word and um
and so now they they uh and then here it
turns out that they have this uh
reference to 1949 unpublished song
titled
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
and um and it turned out then that um uh
here's the reference for 1967 decisions
U.S courts involving copyright the
complaint alleges copyright infringement
of plaintiff's song uh by defendants um
okay and all variants of this tongue
twister will here and after be referred
to collectively as the word
okay so you know there's a there's a lot
of good stuff in his in his in his
Oxford English in the OED okay and uh
all right
um
another another dictionary that I use a
lot is this American Heritage dictionary
this one was this one uh is you can see
by and I use it a lot by by looking at
the cover of the thing
um and this one um
um was based on uh lots of uh lots of
input of of contemporary texts uh that
they that they then process through a
computer and and used it but the main
unique features of it are the usage
notes that they have which are
especially helpful now as I said the
other day I looked it up I looked up
replace by and I couldn't find I
couldn't find the I went on that but I
but I but a similar thing was compare
let me look at let's look up the word
compare and see how
and the question is what what do you say
compare it to something or compare it
with something uh must be in the
previous
page and so here's the here's an example
that says um
used with two C usage note below here it
says use with width usage note below so
usage note okay and there's many usage
notes in this uh I don't know hundreds
and hundreds of usage notes so it'll say
and then they had a panel of about 150
people called their usage panel and they
sent them then this guy William Morris
the editor sent out to the usage panel a
questionnaire saying how would you
consider this acceptable and not
acceptable a long questionnaire and um
so one of the things on his list was
compare two and so 71 of the usage panel
uh would say that it's the only way to
say when you're representing a similar
or likening so compare a voice to
thunder you wouldn't say compare a voice
with thunder in such comparisons or
similarities are often metaphorical
rather than real and so on so they could
then it says compare with is the only
acceptable form in the extent of
examining in order to note similarities
or difference compare Shelley's poetry
with wordsworths okay and here are the
things that compare to R such and such
so informally
to and with are often used
interchangeably in these examples in
formal usage only compare with is
acceptable in intransitive case being
worthy of comparison promises do not
compare with Deeds
you would never say promises compared do
not compare two D's even in informal
issues so that's what and I was these
usage notes are I give you also a
percentage of how many people would feel
about this uh this particular way and so
that's a good thing the other really
neat thing about this is the
um is the appendix that Co that takes it
into the um the indoor Indo-European
root words and um so it'll say c
Pera in appendix and so you go back to
the appendix here and the appendix will
tell you
all the different words that are like
that use pear that use this this that
come from p-e-r-e and this is just this
endless Amusement to learn about the
language
um
and so you get words like parcel par
compart or party uh and uh comparison
here coming from it and the word pair
with the same all these words paramutual
um somehow uh deriving from the
Indo-European root like this and it's a
good way to understand Language by going
into this that this uh discipline so
that's a lot of fun
oh another another dictionary that
somebody sent me when I was working on
the tech project and I hadn't I didn't
Discover it myself because you get given
to me by the by a man let it say uh uh
but I I really find it very uh
extraordinarily useful as I'm writing
this book concrete math now it's it's
contemporary English and it's very good
for really the words that people are
using now if you want to look up a
historical word uh you won't find it in
here
um but if you want to find out what
people are saying uh like if you're a
foreigner wants to learn what um the
language of the street or the language
of uh that you hear every day this is
about actually very good because also
the the definitions are are cast in very
simple English and and uh I I was trying
to as I was writing a couple of days ago
I wanted to use the word
mind bending or mind-boggling or mind
expanding I was trying to think of which
of these would be the right one and I
wanted to figure out what the usage was
so I looked it up in random house on a
bridge I looked it up in OED I looked it
up in American Heritage they didn't have
these words mind bending was not a was
was not in in any of those dictionaries
so I looked up here
mind
and not so they have mind bending they
have mind blowing mind-boggling
and mind expanding and so on so all
these um all these terms that I that
would really weren't in the um these
other pictionaries though is explained
here rather
rather clearly what if and so I decided
not to use any of them but no I well no
but I anyway this answered my question
as to what I wanted to do for for for
usage for the for the language of today
so so I like this um this dictionary for
that purpose
my wife uh
um tells me she uses this book at least
once a day I um this is for I mentioned
that some people uh uh are the way they
learn to read or something uh
um means that they aren't that good at
remembering the spellings of words and
so so this is uh this has uh the most
most used words of English and uh
and uh and and it's at the point where
and and you can you can quickly scan it
if you don't know how to spell it you
can find it pretty quick uh the one that
you you know uh and so uh that so she
she says this is uh you know it was
pretty cheap thing and it was quite
convenient So So she recommends that and
now they're very very important
um when I have two of these one one at
home and one at school because like uh
because I'll be doing writing in both
places is to have have a thesaurus I I
hope everyone knows the the use of this
to find synonyms for words you look up
the you you look up a word and let's
look up mind I don't think mind-boggling
was in this one either but let's see
uh where it is here so you look it up in
the back part which is like an which is
like a dictionary
of course online would be
would be better oh you see we have some
things here we have mind-blowing mind
boggler mind boggling so we could look
up in mind-boggling under 920.12
and uh so back in the first part 9 9
20.12
uh will be
um
astonishing amazing surprising startling
astounding and so on
um
and uh and mind-boggling gets in there
okay so you've got references to uh to
other similar words and then those will
lead you to other ones now now the uh
the the the the thesaurus is not is
something that uh you I use in many many
different ways sometimes there's I know
there's a word for something I just
can't think of it and I and uh so this
will this will lead me to it
um otherwise I'll I'll have a sentence
where I don't want to use the word
values over and over again but I or a
paragraph where I've used a certain word
and I I need another I need another word
for variety otherwise it's too it's too
uh boring
um and uh of course you you can if you
choose the wrong word it's terrible uh
so but the thesaurus will help you find
it find a word that you can't remember
um but uh less obvious use of it is in
is in
um is actually for in computer science
uh or you're you're working doing some
research you need a you need to make a
definition of that of a of a term that's
it doesn't have you have to choose the
right word for something I mean there's
there's a word like stack for example
which we use in computer science and
there's a word like Heap which we use in
several ways in computer science
unfortunately but there's somebody had
to decide to cause this a stack and
somebody had to in fact Dexter says that
he uh and that he used the Dutch word
for stack for this for this purpose
though uh went in his own when he was
starting to program but the uh the the
uh there's many times when when you're
writing a paper you have to have to make
up a term for something that's going to
be used elsewhere that term is going to
be a good like and you have to be
careful when you do this because
um if the if the work you do is at all
important people are going to be
starting to use this term it's going to
become something some entry in a
dictionary someday it's a big
responsibility I didn't realize this at
first I just you know chose a turn that
was the first one that came into my head
and and uh uh and I I guess I had a
notation LR of K for certain kinds of
grammars and uh and there was no
um and when I did this I didn't put any
thought to it at all I just I just
needed the symbol to to use for a
concept I was using in my paper
um then afterwards I found out that
there were a lot of you know there were
there were lots of other papers being
written using this notation I didn't
really care for it very much if I I
thought of something much better uh so
four or five years later I I thought of
another LL of K to go with l r of K and
RL of K and RR of K and to make these
all meaningful just in order to sort of
justify the notation I had inflicted on
the world so that it wouldn't be too
terrible after all
um many other uh but when you when you
uh choose a word it's it's uh it's it's
useful to uh it's it's important to try
to consider
um that it does the right word and so uh
like I was working on the the web
programming system uh for literate
programming we'll be talking about that
next week the
uh there was a I I didn't have a name
for it for a long time and I and I I had
to find a name for this for this system
and uh played around with a lot of
different ones and used the thesaurus
chase down all kinds of different ideas
as to which aspects of it there's a
bilingual aspect and so we tried to find
out we we had uh various candidate names
but using a thesaurus for for to to help
you invent the right technical term is a
good is is an important resource I think
um well I can't yeah so I can't live
without a thesaurus nearby uh so I have
one at this is one I have at Stanford
and I have another one at home
uh we'll go in my chair right where I
usually write
any questions on this David I have one
question that OED supplement that's just
that was it the oeds
is that going to be one day incorporated
into the other yeah yeah in this new
version it's it's all in fact one of the
things in the supplement I noticed that
they would say delete
parts of the original dictionary that
they now have a better you know they
they override some of the things in here
so the supplement
um
I asked Mary Claire that she she uh goes
frequently to work with them I think
so yeah well I I don't know the dates of
it but um
they have a computer program
for a typesetting it called called
because OED appears in girdle's name
typesetting is a it's a quite a it's
quite a
massive uh complication for type setting
because there are many references from
Arabic and other things and you know
like many other different scripts have
to be represented among all the
definitions
okay now what
are these in Tech no this is this is a
well maybe uh maybe Good Will uses some
of the algorithms of tech but it's not
no no they could have put it in Tech I
suppose if tech had been finished
earlier they might have done it but they
they were they started that project
quite a long time ago
uh there was a but they just uh I find I
think it was maybe eight years ago they
finally decided to destroy the type they
had to saved all this metal
every page was a certain metal type and
there was some some place in Oxford
where these were all stored and finding
because they thought they could never
ever you know have it have it redone
again but they didn't know what to do
because these supplements were coming
along so finally uh they decided to to
melt the type all down
ask Mary about that about that that's
that's what I've heard I'm not
absolutely sure what
yeah I don't know actually that's a good
point uh I bought a couple of uh things
like that before they were mounted down
I have a font of Zap Optima type for
example so on we're gonna do our
Christmas card with it
um okay yes I'm on the topic of
dictionaries
um do you have any comments on British
spellings versus American siblings and
especially when books might be of an
Internet yes yeah one of the few papers
I wrote in foreign language was when I
published in the Canadian Journal of
mathematics and uh and I I was talking
about coloring and and so it was spelled
with a u in this paper and
and um uh uh there's uh in the labor
party and so on so there and there's a
license many other words that that are
spelled different in different ways and
uh uh so I got a note there's a new edit
a new Journal coming out next year
called EP odd which means electronic
publishing
something oh the oh I can't remember
what the odd stands for but it's a and
the other and the editorial part and the
other American and British editors both
and so he said that the Americans should
write and spell their own style in
British IT spell their own style and you
would mix the two in one article only if
you were talking about the labor of the
British labor party and then you would
uh he had some examples where where he
mixed you know he where he uh of a
sentence where you had to talk about the
UK defense establishment and the
department and the U.S Department of
Defense in this and you would spell them
you would spell them in the way of the
of the uh of the country where they
really are uh is that on is that
answering your question
um so so if you're if you're uh
uh you know those are unders
understandable uh that you would use
that there's also of course choices of
words and especially when you talk about
automobiles or something like that the
uh everything changes the boot instead
of the trunk and
um
you get into a lift
the uh my my uh
um my kids when we went to Norway that
uh
they people would tell them to mind the
traffic and they didn't know that this
meant watch out for cars you know like
and so people so we had to be with them
even though even though even though
people were speaking English to them
it's okay to write in your own uh in
your own uh version of being of English
or whatever whatever you whatever is
right for you so is it true then you'd
always default to let's say a
Merriam-Webster or American Heritage
spelling versus the Oxford for instance
I would uh uh in my own books yeah in
fact I well now I I what was it uh last
yesterday I had to figure out how to
spell dominoes with an e or or without
an e and uh and I looked and and I found
uh overwhelming preference was to have
the e in there even in America so
so I so I kept it in
um
and uh let's see what's it gonna say or
some other
question came up yeah yeah uh they you
know you
but it's the it's your audience who is
going to be the the one that that's
that's if you think the audience wants
to be wants the other spelling then you
should write for them
I I did write it when I was in Norway I
wrote an article for publication which
is sort of like scientific Norwegian uh
you know as equivalent of Scientific
American in Norway and and I tried to uh
and I try and I and I tried to write
something that would that would be good
in our region although I don't know the
language very well at all uh so then I
started also I would keep track of how
many of my words actually survived into
the final into the final thing but when
I but when I chose symbols for example
there was a I was talking about an
algorithm that had a left and a right to
it and so I wouldn't use l and R as the
abbreviations but I would use H and V
which were the for the Norwegian words
uh uh higher in venster oh that's the
vnh for anyway for the and you know so
you choose the you choose uh single
letter names also based on something
that will be conceptually relevant to
the to the reader and uh after I after I
wrote what I thought would be uh uh
reasonably correct with all the uh
knowledge I had studied of the grammar
and everything I showed it to my uh my
friend of mine at the math Institute who
was a
um who who went over it and Polished it
for style and uh and then we sent it to
the to the editorial office which also
goes through and and does rewrites
everything again the way Scientific
American does and and so in the final uh
final draft and I I underlined and read
every word that was mine and in green
every word that was rules and uh and uh
left the the other ones the new ones are
brown or something and I and my own
came to about 30 of the final and it was
about about a three-way split I guess
equally equally so didn't get through
and it
when I do it here of of uh oh right now
I I I I
get almost 100 I think
uh I mean it would be between 95 and 100
for sure coming through now but uh
I don't know
um okay any other questions that yeah
on a contemporary usage when you wrote
uh when you content yeah in concrete
mathematics you go there there's a
section where it goes through a proof
yeah at the end it concludes you know
it's like it's talking to the judge in
People's Court whose name I can never
remember oh that's right yeah yeah and I
yeah I got that from my son I asked him
who would be a mcinerney uh was not the
one but we changed it to judge Judge
Wapner yeah because yeah and I just said
to John what would be a a good judge to
use for uh for for his generation yeah
is that was a good question okay
yeah people's car is that yeah I just I
just wondered you know
right
yeah I have no idea but uh but Lauren
had another judge's name in there and I
asked John if he knew that name and he
said no so
yeah
that was the judge when you were on jury
duty oh okay
uh-huh
so you will probably enjoy doing it when
you were writing that chapter okay so
this is the way you remembered it
oh okay
um
yeah there's a lot of uh parts of the
textbook that that all of a sudden they
have Welsh examples because that was the
month I I went to Wales and uh things
like that yeah so those little traces uh
appear in books don't they
um now uh So speaking of concrete math I
have a few more notes in here of the
things that that I noted as I was going
through this before and after so let's
try to get through this I
um the first thing I I I wanted to to
mention is the idea is uh something I I
again very often when I when I'm doing
the the editing for flow I find I'll
break up a sentence by changing the
semicolon to a period so
um here it says the next one is a bit
more difficult and then I decided to
stop the sentence in new sentence it can
be reduced to randomized convolution by
a sequence of Transformations but we can
just leave and so on
who somehow when the first draft it
sounded like I wanted a semicolon here
because I was going to get through
something quickly but but afterwards it
was really so separate there was no
point in trying to join the tour getting
in your logical relation between the two
um and uh now I I another thing here I
started a new paragraph right right
right this symbol means you know switch
to a new paragraph here uh because here
let's look at the context before moving
on this took a proof for two more of the
identities in table three and it's easy
to prove this one and then I was gonna
you know if I if I could finish in the
same paragraph the proof of both of them
then then then fine but it turned out
um uh I I didn't get I I got through the
proof of the first one in one sentence
it was sort of a trivial thing but this
proof of the second one
um was going to go on for a ways and so
um I might as well start a new paragraph
there then in order to reinforce the uh
the structure of the whole thing and I
added a new sentence here a new
paragraph here uh so much for table 5.3
and uh so then the infrastructure of the
of that pick no that part would be would
be uh would be clear
okay once again here's another place
where I start change a semicolon to a
period i
um started and usually you don't start a
sentence with the word and but
if if you're set up for it it's okay
to break that rule once in a while
um
uh pronoun reference
um two things about this derivation are
worthy of note first it's a great
convenience to be summing over all
integers K now that's bad this it
it sounds like it's it's this derivation
it's a great derivation no the
starvation is a great convenience no
it's just uh it's uh this word this
sentence by itself might be fine it's a
great convenience to be something
overall interest K but not when you when
you're talking about this derivation so
so clearly there so I had to
um rewrite the sentence so that it
completely different structure
another another problem in um in
mathematical text is that you get long
formulas that don't fit
uh and and displays it would you know in
fact look uh let's see where do I get
here's here's one you see it's
overlapping the equation number
um so so this is this is going on top so
I had to so this symbol means to me
break it into two lines move this down
it's the second line
you know so and uh so the second line uh
uh is is all there and there's room for
the number
um now if this is something that um the
author of a paper can do better than uh
than somebody who doesn't understand the
paper the author can sometimes re change
the whole formula so that it doesn't
need to be broken or something like this
and so that's one of the uh nice things
about that type setting is coming in now
that that uh that I think uh uh a matter
of exposition in how to break a display
uh can actually I think it's worthwhile
to for the author to put a little to put
those those few minutes into it it does
improve it over something it would be if
this will be done mechanically but then
you get to a formula like this which
even after I put it on the second line
it's 2y
um and uh so I I either have to to
change the mathematics and introduce a
new symbol like I could introduce the
symbol D uh capital S for a plus b plus
C plus d or something like that or in
this case I I noticed that uh really
there was a lot of space around these
plus signs I didn't need so I so I just
um I just um close up around all the
plus signs and then there was plenty of
plenty of room to get it in
um so so properly uh
now here's another formula that was too
wide I I could get rid of some space in
the plus sign here bringing these two
parenthesis School closer together and
it would fit okay
sorry I had to think you have a filler
with this now why not but uh anybody
working with with uh this is my page
talking about the hairiest uh the
hairiest sum of binomial coefficients
known and uh this is the my my uh my
idea as to what the what the champ is
and so no wonder I had a little trouble
getting it into the to the line question
uh yeah when you're breaking it I notice
you're taking the equal sign down to the
next line yeah that's down here again
yeah that's standard is it's funny the
rule for in in a displayed formula is
that that you start the next line with
the operator uh uh equals or Plus or
whatever but it but but in in text it's
the opposite in text you leave the
equals at the right hand margin and and
You Begin the next at the at the left if
the it's just backwards but uh that's
the way that's the way it's most
commonly done
okay now more of the same
um here was a case where I
where uh as I was reading this the
second time I noticed that
um that I didn't want that I didn't want
to use the the letters A and B later on
there's a B in the uh in the next page
here uh that it would be that was
conflicting with other things that I
would be using so I decided um to change
it all to q and r q a a to q and B to R
in this in this whole in this whole
discussion which goes on for several
pages so this is a this is an example of
the great advantage of text editors
where you can where you can make a
systematic search for everything what a
with a subscript and you can replace it
uh and be sure that you've got them all
um much harder to do that in the old
days and so we can improve otherwise
there would have been
such a disincentive to make the change
of I would have probably not come up
with as good a book
um
what did I note here
here it says uh some involving two
binomial coefficients it says wait a
minute where's the second binomial
coefficient
and uh but I don't know why this is
similar to what I noticed before when I
read this at speed I didn't catch what
this I didn't catch the point of this of
this uh of this question here and so I I
added this where's the second binomial
coefficient named in the title of this
problem
um but it's
I think it's it uh but I liked the
general idea that Oren put in here
because it has a nice break in style it
keeps the thing Lively
to uh to do this and and uh the whole
point of this was then that we could
rewrite this K as a binomial coefficient
K choose one and and and it was going to
uh
um and it was going to then be a better
approach to a problem we already had
done before
um
see here's a case of um
out of uh of tens
um
uh I I didn't
I didn't uh I solved the problem two
ways and got two different answers
and so um they
let's see it was Zero what did I what do
I mean here though
the sum was zero in all cases
um our other path of the solution told
us that the sum was zero in all cases
and and since it isn't you know I said
usually if it's a statement of fact it
should be present tense all the time but
uh but our it told us that the sum was
Zero but it was actually it wasn't the
fact it was only a fact that we believed
at the time right so I think was is the
proper tense here but it's a
it's a problem let's see bad break
here's another case where I had a large
formula that had to be broken between
lines now in this case
this is a very bad place to break after
this minus sign because of the you know
it's a fourth Tuple here
um and so I inserted a word uh the I
started the word equation here so I
would have when I originally wrote it it
was just namely 521 but after now this
is mainly Phi equation 521 and then I I
told Tech that in this case it would be
okay to break after this comma here
usually Tech will never break after a
comma it would look it usually looks
wrong but this time it was okay so I
think um
if we go to this
uh let's see where see how it came out
in the in the after
version here round seven here we go
okay so actually by by um
by inserting the new word equation there
the tech was able then to to to figure
out to actually work it work the thing
out by hyphenating the word in the first
line and stuff that was
was forbidden to do before so it now it
now found a way to do it without
breaking after that comment so
um
okay now there's not too many more
things here here's an example of a case
where I decided to display a formula
that um uh
that uh look didn't look right because I
had to break it you know here and here
it was breaking in the middle it would
have been okay to break after the equal
sign but uh didn't work out and I didn't
want to insert any more words besides I
realized this formula could very well be
displayed and so this formula is not is
now displayed and that solved the
problem also fixed up the end of the
paragraph
rather well
um
how are we doing am I I still got some a
little bit of time
um
the uh uh
one of the most common
um
if errors that I think
mathematicians make when they get their
own typesetting system is to overuse
I overuse the form of fractions where
you have you have one the numerator over
the denominator as opposed to the slash
form of the fractions where you would
say one slash two instead of one over
two now this doesn't look extremely bad
here but I change it I think it looks
better in one slash two let's see what
see if we can
compare the two uh before and after you
see that one there and here's the here's
the new one
I think it's a little a little easier to
read there in that way but what the what
mathematicians almost always overdo the
use of of uh trying to put a fraction in
the text uh with tiny little numbers
over the other one and here it's since
it's already in the in the upper part of
us of a small type this this one goes
into the small small type instead of the
so so
um
moral of this is to is to convert
fractions to a slashed form uh we when
they're in text uh typically it's this
is some something that copy editors and
math journal stuff
um and do that's one thing in
mathematics they know a lot about they
don't know really what the mathematics
means but they know the difference
between um you know that they know that
when they they when they go one over n
plus one they have to do that as one
slash and they have to insert a
parenthesis to get the N plus one in
there they they know enough about
putting putting in a parenthesis and
taking out in slashes because that's the
one most common changes that a copy
editor of a math journal has to has to
make
um here was a example I just wanted to
say where I
where um sometimes it sometimes uh I I
went the other way and and actually
changed the period to a semicolon
um this this sentence here I wanted to I
you know I had a period and start a new
sentence but I did feel as I was reading
it through that I wanted to go
I want to go at high speed through this
uh and have the and have the uh the key
that the second part of the sentence was
really uh joined very much to the first
so I did so I don't always go the other
way I don't semicolons aren't
necessarily always evil
um and uh more of the same kinds of
things over and over again until we get
to the end of the chapter exercises
um
and um I just want to say a few words
about exercises that this is the this is
where you have to be especially careful
as you're riding because you're you're
giving somebody something with no
context to base it on so you can't be
ambiguous Any teacher who knows when
he's given his first exam will find out
that the students are solving different
problems and he thought they were being
they were asked to solve or something
got a lot harder because you thought
something was obvious and it wasn't so
when you when you're studying exercises
you got to be especially careful to have
a bit of enough redundancy in there the
person won't misunderstand the point of
the exercise for this reason exercise
are the hardest things to translate into
another language and uh there's a book a
famous book called
book that came out in 1924 I think it
was that was one of the best books of
the 20th century it's 50 years before
that book was public was translated into
another more than 50 years of 60 years I
think before the book was translated
into any other language finally the
English language Edition came out
um and it's because it was just so darn
hard to translate every problem was sort
of it had to be done uh with with just
the right amount of state of of nuances
that a reader would understand it and uh
if you've ever done a translation
project for yourself from another
language you you realize that when you
get to the exercise Parts is the hardest
part for you to understand
um it's hardest to understand a
newspaper headline if you're going to
alert a foreign country otherwise
because you don't know the jargon of
those headlines so exercise is a special
uh Special Care is needed the answers to
exercises is another another change of
style here here uh we dropped a lot of
the rules of exposition because we're
trying to be we're trying to be brief uh
we only need to give enough of a hint at
the answer can be reconstructed we don't
have to write the answer with a great
deal of sugary Exposition as we do in
the in the text itself so for example I
I start out a lot of a lot of things
with a symbol
F of K is is a polynomial I would never
do that in the middle of a proof but I
do it in the answer no problem
another thing I should mention about
answers is it exercises sources now I've
got these are my I hadn't uh
um run the biblio the bibliography file
up to date so these were new sources
that there was proofreading this but
there's a but nowadays there's a
copyright law that's different from the
way it was uh when I started writing the
art of computer programming and I'm not
supposed to use anything in my book that
I don't credit to this to its source if
somebody if I if I use an exercise and
give a give a problem in a in a book
that that was somebody out that has
appeared in anywhere else I should give
credit to that person get permission
from that person to use it officially uh
before I before I do this now um now now
mathematicians have been having been
suing each other for using their
exercises in text so far and they're
they're just usually just delighted to
to be named
um uh you know to uh at all but you
should you should credit them uh and um
and I'm not going to write letters like
probably to everybody asking for
permission but I should but I think uh
theoretically I should and there's a
publisher design we'll have to delay the
publication of the book until these
letters come back
so this is but but it's a good idea that
credit sources in fact it's been very
frustrating to me to find to try to
trace the history of so many subjects in
mathematics and I and somebody will say
this is uh
um uh lagrange's inequality and and uh
when heck did LaGrange ever published it
uh and and I and I still haven't been
able to find it in fact I I spent four
hours looking through his collected
works and wasn't able to find that
inequality anywhere
um
and uh so uh uh having sources that I
think will be a good tradition it'll be
much more easy to trace down the history
of these things as it wasn't that
okay see you next week
foreign